[Applause]
two sad men on Batman welcome the fat
man hi Batman I'm Kevin Smith hi I'm
Mark Barnard hey welcome back lady I'm
the first fat man I'm Batman of the year
2018 we are as always at the scum and
villainy Cantina here on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California put
your hands together so the folks at home
know you're real now for anyone who's
not here this evening you don't
appreciate the lengths that Angelenos
have had to go to get to the show
tonight it's [ __ ] raining here and as
I said to my wife today I was like we
went to order a pizza you know
it's [ __ ] up I didn't know this some
pizza places don't do deliver anymore
cuz they're just like call GrubHub or or
was the other one seamless apparently
there's a lot of them but but like the
pizza part they don't have a dedicated
delivery person somebody will just come
like post mates will come and pick it up
and [ __ ] so I told my wife today I was
like hey man can you order a pizza like
we're driving I was driving so she
wasn't driving I was like do [ __ ]
something and so I said order a pizza
would you and she went to order from the
place you should go [ __ ] and I was like
what she's like there's a surge and I
was like what does that mean she's like
because there's so many people ordering
pizza and ordering food to be delivered
that the surge rate like on uber they
charge you more if you order at that
particular point she's like we got to
pay an extra five bucks I was like it's
[ __ ] worth it to not leave that house
and she's like you're the problem you
know cuz you're willing to pay these
surge price and the best part that was
that you're in the car like I don't
leave the house
we're out of the house I know we don't
want to stop the car I didn't want to
swing it was raining really hard
I said somehow if I was like in this
town like when it rains it's like snow
and other places where people are like
oh [ __ ] slow down don't move let's stay
in the house and [ __ ] keep the kids home
like I woke up this morning to alerts
it's raining keep your children home
from school so it took a long time for
everybody but to get here I'd assume
thank you so much for doing so I spent
last week January first I did a
Hollywood babble-on on New Year's Eve
and then eight hours later oh right on
Ralph's beer and then eight hours later
I was on a plane and went to Florida
went to Sarasota to work with the
Ringling College of Art and Design kids
and this company called divid Digital
caviar and SimCorp productions make it a
flick we're like 70% of the crew is made
up of students from Ringling so the idea
is they're on a set like learning rather
than just being in the classroom are
they learning to be clowns when they're
not helping you out yet they don't do
that down there no no well now that the
circus is gone like nobody even
references it anymore
like what built all this they like shut
the [ __ ] off so it but bring like the
College Art and Design been there since
like 1935 like John Ringling at one
point was richest human being in the
world and so he built this entire town
he had massive art collection just like
the guy they made the movie about what's
his name Getty so he like he they've got
the best of everything down there and
stuff so that school is one of those
places and they instituted a film school
like 12 years ago or something and the
film schools really emerged it become
like one of the hottest film schools in
the country
so last July we went down and shot a
segment of this horror anthology movie
I'm doing is kind of like creep show
called Kilroy Was Here
so we did a bunch in July and when it
was [ __ ] hot and we went back in
January January 1st I flew down we did
another segment and when I got there I
was like I haven't seen you folks in a
year and they're like you were here in
June and I was like wow it feels like it
was such a long time
we go man but they're like you're high
and I was like there it is but they're
all sweet they all remembered they're
like you got us ice cream and that
triggered a memorizing oh [ __ ] you're
right
like I only what I generally like I'm at
this age in my life and career where
it's like I love making movies I still
treat it special in shift but I also
don't treat it too special like you know
like our kid we didn't fetishize our kid
you know what I'm saying like hey she's
our kid but I was never like what a
little angel I'm like boy she says
stupid [ __ ] like keep it real so you
know I'm the job like I tend to just
stray from set sometimes I'm like how
long we got there like 10 minutes I'm
like well I'm gonna go but like if if
you guys are ready and I'm not here just
shoot a few and they're like how are we
gonna drink without director I'm like
you'll figure it out so so I'll go and
pick up like on Kilroy it was so [ __ ]
hot in July and we were all sweating to
see that humidity down in [ __ ]
Florida swamp hot oh my god and there
were alligators nearby and [ __ ] like
there was a lady where we were shooting
in the park ranger lady and stuff she
was rolling by she's like oh I know you
and I say hey what are you doing man
like look for alligator she's like yeah
we found one like two blocks back and I
was like are you [ __ ] serious and
she's like I'm a park ranger yes all we
do is look out for allegations like just
don't [ __ ] with him he won't [ __ ] with
you I was like that's it like you don't
want to give me a pointy stick or a
shotgun or something like that just some
sound advice don't [ __ ] with him she's
like generally they he won't come over
here he sees all these lights he won't
be here but we'll keep an eye on him
we'll keep like circling and stuff so I
was there shooting and I was like I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here there's
an alligator here so I went to the like
food store and I bought a bunch of ice
cream and stuff and then came back and I
was hey wants ice cream and I was bad in
a big-ass bag and I was having everybody
grab their ice cream and stuff so when I
came back they were like you bought us
ice cream and I said oh yeah that's
right I remember that and for the rest
of the week
like I kept hearing about the like you
bought us ice cream at one time and I
was like yeah but that like stopped
asking for ice cream
and I would have went and got ice cream
but it was so [ __ ] cold was my point
last summer we were down there was hot
went in January January first and
there's this like cold snap going across
the East Coast which includes somehow
Florida so it was 35 degrees at one
point in Florida and I was like you know
trying to smoke out on the balcony and
like if you're in Chicago and you're
trying to smoke on the balcony you get
it it's cold he likes [ __ ] in Chicago
so you put on you know couple coats and
[ __ ]
listen Florida at a bathrobe a [ __ ]
coat and a blanket wrapped around me so
I could sit on the balcony smoke a joint
and be like fufufu Florida is so [ __ ]
cold so I didn't get any ice cream but I
did at one point
I've got donuts and I also got
McDonald's I wanted to a McDonald's it
like this was [ __ ] up instead nothing
to do with the show but just a side note
I wanted to a Dunkin Donuts and like I
was like well let's get there's 60
people on the crew get 10 dozen donuts
and stuff and everybody get pass out
donuts we go on a Dunkin Donuts it's a
Sunday and let's say not 12 1 o'clock so
they've had a morning rush of sorts I
understand it's Sunday people like
donuts on Sunday place is called Dunkin
Donuts so if I go in there and I'm like
give me all the donuts don't you think
they'd be like oh my god take the
[ __ ] donuts closing early yeah
exactly like that's our manifesto to
sell you all the donuts we [ __ ] can
and I just made their job easier so I
came in and I was like 10 Donuts and
that place froze up as if I was like
give me all your money put it in a bag
like they're like wow we got to ask the
manager and the manager had to call
somebody to be like can we sell 10
Donuts Oh 10 dozen donuts in a row and
[ __ ] and I was like can we break it up
like I buy some and for this person buy
some and they were like well now you
told us no and so
[Laughter]
it was crazy man and so couldn't get as
many as I wanted but did get a decent
amount and stuff but it was a process of
about 15 20 minutes to see if they could
sell the donuts to his lawn I was just
like if I owned that franchise I'd be
like if somebody comes in asking for 10
dozen donuts trying to sell him [ __ ]
20 man like oh my god so got the donuts
went back at night I went to McDonald's
it shows you the difference between the
two I went to McDonald's because it was
closest like burger joint and it was
light and and and it was look starting
to get chilly so I was like oh I'll get
burgers and cheeseburgers for everybody
so I go into the McDonald's and I was
like yeah I'm interested in getting they
say 40 hamburgers and 40 cheeseburgers
how long would that take and she goes
seven minutes that clown trains them
right man that's like if somebody comes
in trying to buy a vast amount of our
shitty food [ __ ] sell it to oh man so
I went and got a bunch of burgers then
hand out of the burgers you drive by
Dunkin Donuts just waving yeah this is
how you do business so I was down there
shooting in July now shooting for the
last week there was really really chilly
but I had a great time shot some fun
[ __ ] Mona and then just got home
literally the other day but it was we
were working with Robert Kurtzman one of
the creators of the kmb effects group
the you know people that do prosthetics
and stuff like that on all the movies
you ever saw growing up including like
all the evil Dead's and so he did our
tusk walrus he created the walrus and
tusk I remember he read the script and
we got a phone call and he's like I was
like I don't know how to describe what
I'm looking for he goes frankenstein
walrus and I go oh my god yes that's
exactly it and so he built that and
stuff so I I was working with him on on
this as well and had to do some bloody
effects people get machete din the face
and machete through the gut and as a kid
who grew up on 80s horror movies with
prosthetics more than like CG like I was
sitting there watching a guy
who
this on evil dead so like you know you'd
be like hey man what if we move wood
over here and Kurtzman goes yeah you
could but what we learned on Evil Dead
was if you go over here and you realize
he's referencing [ __ ] cinema history
you know and you're like oh it's
breathtaking in [ __ ] so we got to hatch
it a [ __ ] in the face and I see
how they do it I never did a reverse in
my life I don't think maybe once and
Mallrats
when he's gone for that tape and [ __ ]
then the tape falls into his hand I
think we did a like a filament wire and
pulled it and then ran it in Reverse
maybe if I can remember correctly but
I've never I can't remember really doing
it
so this felt like my first at least my
first reverse effect of somebody getting
chopped in the face in order to do that
in order to hit you in the face with a
machete it starts there and then you
shoot it in Reverse so every motion has
to look like that so it's really hard on
the person getting hit in the face
because you have to go from oh [ __ ] I'm
hitting the face - this is what I look
like before I got hit in the face like
you know step backwards it's kind of
unique skill man but like I said look
I've never done this before
ladies and gentlemen bob has the con
what do you say the Condor the comp the
con what a co NN what does that mean I
don't know maritime [ __ ] I I got it from
Hartford October that's all I can say
yeah but I didn't know if it was common
look if it was calm it's like command
center I'm like I get that I think it's
con for control but I don't know where
the second aim comes from someone with
some military I think it was awesome -
yeah like I was in the military but I
don't [ __ ] know shame on me they
trained you guys right you're like
immediately filled with shame or
knowledge take a load off man have a
drink it's okay not to know none of us
[ __ ] know man it was either enter
October or Wrath of Khan it was the
first time I ever heard that mr. mr.
Saavik Telecom I thought you meant you
have the Conn like sorry it was fun to
be like Bob you have the Conn and I
might have said calm and people like I
don't get it
and so we used to be clowns but yeah I
gave him the set and watched some work
and had him be like okay three two one
go it's simple then we have the
technology now
to play it backwards and watch it and
see if it works like he's like we didn't
have this back in the day we didn't have
like video cysts or anything he's like
so we couldn't see it we were just
hoping that would work and we'd see that
when we developed the film but there you
could do it right there on the [ __ ]
set and it was fun dude it was it was so
dope
like I forget but before I fell in love
with comedy and [ __ ] like that I was
like a like a rubber horror kid I love
that [ __ ] like [ __ ] blood and guts
exploding and should I and not like the
torture porn [ __ ] I don't like that the
Jason's the Freddie the prom nights the
Halloween's of course and stuff so it
was fun to do that for a week felt like
fantasy camp and since you're kind of
working with kids who haven't worked yet
professionally they're still like oh
you're the guy that did clerks as
opposed to oh you did yoga hosers so
they're still looking at you like you've
done something and and it's kind of it's
kind of nice like you know the whole
thing they've got passion you know and I
keep telling on that's like I work at an
industry where I meet a lot of people
who age out of this job but first they
head toward it but then you know they
they get sick of it I don't know how I
don't ever lose that man you guys got
all the passion and enthusiasm in the
world and [ __ ]
so it was good it was nice like way to
start 2018 to recharge my batteries but
it's I got to work with Jason Mewes of
course got to work with him I [ __ ]
wake up and work with them every day but
I brought him down and he he played a
janitor for the second time he's career
he was on a TV show called table in the
book of evil where he played a janitor
so in this short that one of the shorts
and the anthology I was like I need you
to play a Jenner he's like I could
[ __ ] do that I got experience so he
came down and played my daughter came
down and played man it was a good time
and the monster looks [ __ ] up it's
based on Kilroy like the idea of the guy
who hangs over the wall in the fence so
Kurt spending when he's creating the
makeup you know I was like go for it man
he's like what do you want me to do
about the nose I said don't make it look
exactly like her word but suggestive our
character gets like burnin [ __ ] so he
loses all features so you know and he
melts and that's why the nose we
that way so I said let me see what that
would look like in the real world and
the first rendition of it man he has
this like long ass nose like the drawing
that hangs real low and so I got on the
phone with Bob and I was just like it's
just a giant [ __ ] isn't it Bob he's like
I can't help with us what a big long
dangly [ __ ] nose looks like and Bob's
the guy that made Marky Mark's dick on
Boogie Nights so he goes and you know I
know how to do a rubber dick you know so
we had him scale it back and the effect
is still fairly ridiculous looking when
you see it but you know he's also
hatchet in you and machete in you at the
same time so maybe it's you know it's a
you know how to feel you're looking at
me like that looks weird and then you're
like oh [ __ ] he's a bloody killer who
eats babies and [ __ ] like that he's this
figure of myth suburban legend shows it
so I'm having a [ __ ] blast so I come
home like ready to face the new year be
creative and it looks like we're getting
ever closer to shoot was starting Jay
and Silent Bob reboot this was a nice
like palate cleanser nice kind of like
ooh the way to kick off for you what
you've been up to uh I ordered
McDonald's from ubereats
I did that on New Year's Day there's
yeah I was feeling like bringing in the
New Year by hating myself just enough to
leave the house you're so lazy are you
lazy enough to make them bring me
McDonald's which thank you world that's
kind of awesome I had what was for me a
my first ever feature pitch you know
this is no it is when they're in
Hollywood the way the movies work
sometimes there are like I wrote my own
movie and I loved it and I'd love to
death and here please make it and then
there's the the studio has bought a
property and they're looking for writers
to adapt it oh all right yeah and so you
are one of probably 20 or 30 people
coming into the studio offering your
take on the material what you will say
and how you will make it difference what
I do with it
what kind of thing so I had my first one
of those I went in to Sony and pitched a
version of a comic book that they had
bought I don't think I can say which
comic book
but you probably haven't read it and it
sounds like you've got the job with a
son like that only did it probably I've
been read it but it was a fascinating
experience like to have to read
something and digest something and
figuring out how to make it similar
enough to the source material that they
won't bounce you out of the room but
still change enough to show that you did
something and just didn't regurgitate a
book it's an interesting exercise they
have to do and then to sit there and
pitch it to producers and to executives
and in some case the creators of the
book and say here's what I [ __ ] with
the thing that you did that you love for
money
yeah the like and we have some how about
a kickback yeah I mean why don't they
let the creators do it they're like oh
they're they can't because they're
creative you know you would think that
given that they know the book better
than anybody else in the world that they
would have the very least get a shot at
it and maybe the creators did have a
shot and it just didn't fly but
sometimes that's you're too close to it
sometimes it's you you have no distance
and you can't you can't sacrifice the
things that have to be sacrificed to
make it good right you know I mean one
of the one of the things that that I
both like and dislike about Sin City
especially the first one is that it is
just a translation of the book they are
not inventing anything new between them
and sometimes when you adapt a story it
means to change that's that that's
actually what that means is to change
and if you're too close to it you're
unwilling to change it and I think
sometimes they look for outside
perspectives to just add a little curve
on the ball how is the executive class
because you have to sit across from
younger than I am but then again
everybody's younger than I am so that's
fine because I'm 78 years old you guys
you look good I look good I remember
when we got color television
but yeah I mean they were cooling in
with Fuji a stick and they were they
they loved the material and they were
eager to get it made
is there a current stereotype for studio
exec like back in the days they were
hollow and stuff no these guys I mean
we're we're in a weird space where the
people now I'm not running studios but
like in the upper echelons of it are
nerds
you know they grew up like we did there
about our age got a little younger so
they're Star Wars kids and Star Trek
kids they read comic books like they
understand why we're in this glorious
Halcyon age if not entertainment like
they get it there in many ways
responsible for it but they didn't like
what I had to say and let that comic
book show I didn't get the job but
naturally okay you didn't get the job
they didn't hear you suck their dicks
like you just did right oh my god I
would have given you the job Nora and
some young man from very good parentage
I'm sure how do you know any to get the
Javed said we're going different
direction
yeah a couple days later like my agents
called them and was like so how'd it go
it's like no we loved him he was great
but we're going in a different way which
is the way that they say no no we
decided to pursue other options
worthwhile to go through the process
totally totally just to just to get
those miles on the odometer just to say
that I did it to know how it goes to
know what it feels like and it seems
like like I guess that's that's the game
like I've got you know I've wanted and
pitched on things so I guess I have done
that but not I haven't done it in a
feature level in a while I did it with
Superman a long time ago went in and
wound up kind of going this is what I do
but I did it for Sam and switch the
pitch that we're still waiting here that
becomes a BBC America show or not I did
it for I went in on like two last year
year and a half ago I went into Warner
Brothers animation because they wanted
to do something with Plastic Man and the
like you know anything about Plastic Man
I was like oh yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah I know
he turns into a ball alive
[Applause]
so easy to drop I guess so I went in and
talked about what I do wound up writing
the script that I don't think went
anywhere and stuff I was happy with it
but you know and then what was the other
one
Oh buckaroo banzai mhm when I went in
was just like this is what I'd do with
that I guess but yeah it's it's weird
man even you're very gracious about like
these they're people just like us and
one that about the execs but it's weird
to to go in and I mean I guess because
of the podcasts and because like just
the way I work it's weird to sit down
and ask somebody can I be creative for
money you know like it feels weird so I
just try to figure out ways to do it
myself and then hope they come to me and
ask right I mean it's for at least for
me where I am in my career it's a lot of
87 irons in 87 fires and if one of them
happens to be spend a week coming up
with a movie based on this comic book
alright that's cool
didn't work out that's okay there's 86
other irons and maybe one of them most
of them are [ __ ] that I've come up with
that I've created that I'm personally
invested in but sometimes [ __ ]
alright no I'll play in your toy box is
it was that a product of living out in
LA like would you have had that meeting
if you're still living begeez
I don't think so so I don't think so I
think it was can you go over there on
like Thursday and this was a Monday like
yeah I can do that so ultimately it's
all part of the plan you got to be here
and you got to be in a to win it oh my
god did you guys get the reference
and it's pretty nice yeah I just
rewatched that on a plane i rewatch me
and mark
did uh for christmas for the holidays a
commentary track for Batman Begins for
for the fat man Batman podcast the audio
version so people were very happy and so
I started watching Dark Knight mm-hmm to
get ready for the next round and stuff
and I was on a plane for a four hour
flight so they offered it as a choice
Dark Knight's awesome okay I haven't
seen this in a little while it's gonna
be hard to do a commentary track because
so much of the movie you just kind of
stare and going like [ __ ] this isn't
really good yeah like is unbelievably
breathtaking like [ __ ] how do they do
that [ __ ] like it's so wonderful it's a
it's a high [ __ ] bar that like other
comic book movies are still aiming for
at this point I mean certainly not
saying like Marvel hasn't hit that bar
but [ __ ] it's pretty astounding yeah I
feel like The Dark Knight commentary
will be a lot like on the Schwarzenegger
is commentary for Conan the Barbarian
you guys ever listen to that where he's
literally just like so here's why I
chopped the snake he just narrates [ __ ]
that happens on screen oh my god like
five minutes
Batman's getting a new helmet that was
the part of the movie I got really hung
up on man I was like it took
[ __ ] this long to be like let's
just make it a helmet so it can go like
that nope
like all those years Michael Keaton had
to be like come on and even he even a
[ __ ] the start of the Dark Knight
where he's like fighting the Scarecrow
and those dudes in that garage and [ __ ]
like at one point has to look back and
he had to do the whole my whole body
twists like an action figure and then
[ __ ] back so it was kind of dope that
there was a moment where he goes to
Lucius can you [ __ ] fix this you see
this [ __ ] have you like I can't see
anything behind me and they also like
set it up like cuz that's your first
sequence of seeing him in the Dark
Knight is when he peers and [ __ ] up the
drug deal then you don't see him be
Batman again I mean you know he's he's
maybe on the rooftop or something but
he'll see him back in action until he's
in China and he's about to jump off the
building and bust in and steal that dude
so they show him like putting on the
helmet you don't quite get where you're
in a far shot that that is the new cowl
and then they're getting close and
you're like oh [ __ ] man like that yeah
yeah they stole it from Ben Affleck's
daredevil
like because that's what he had was kind
of a separate helmet piece as opposed to
this connected thing it looks [ __ ]
dope then he puts it on and then [ __ ]
spreads the wings which I noticed they
did that in the first two movies is like
Chris Nolan was in love with the idea of
like he's called Batman let's have him
spread out his bet wings and so in
Batman Begins he's always [ __ ] flying
around like at the end of the movie and
[ __ ] and then in this movie like as if
people were like hey man don't [ __ ]
do the flying thing anymore he ain't
[ __ ] Superman Chris Nolan was like go
[ __ ] yourselves and he throw in a bigger
sequence where he's like he's gonna fly
even further in China you know but I
haven't realized it yet but I don't
think did they do a Batman flies in
Batman in The Dark Knight Rises
did he ever pop his wings and fly I
don't know like half the dudes too busy
getting his back broken yeah and getting
his knee brace on I think he does much
flying
that's a limping and hobbling so he
guess by the third movie he's just like
I'm not doubling down on this Batman
flying [ __ ] I've done so much flow ya
know more flowing I've done that let's
have him handle a nuclear bomb
we let them do it the rock climbing
alright so we'll get to that eventually
but I guess we're done with our chit
chat the top right we can be shall we do
you have more to say about the studio
system you like they're tasty I did I
did see I saw your face last night in my
bedroom as I was oh my god turn the
lights down I want to hear this story
sometimes I see your face in my bedroom
to tell my wife I'm like pretend I'm but
hardened yeah like if I'm gonna pretend
you're anybody else it's not gonna be
the other guy on fat man on back I was
watching a screener of the disaster
artist yeah and my wife said did you
know Kevin was in this like he doesn't
tell me everything he does i-i've my kid
came home for the movie she's like what
to see the disaster artist and you're in
it she's like what don't you do I was
yeah Seth and well Franco reached out
with an email at one point as I came in
you know I think about the room I said
yeah so can you come to chat about it
we're gonna throw it in like a little
montage new thing at the beginning of
this movie we're doing and it like went
over it wasn't even far from where I
live it was there for like a half-hour
and completely spaced until I saw the
trailer then I even forgot about me
being in it and [ __ ] and I was just like
oh my god this looks [ __ ] dope and so
yeah when if when it when it came out I
like I forgot
it's nice to be involved with something
that people like for change I didn't
know how to deal with that yeah yeah I
was watching more screeners yeah man
it's dropping in I like the disaster
artist it was a lot and he was [ __ ]
pitch perfect like I'd just won a Golden
Globe Franco from playing that role I
agree with that completely
yeah he was really great enough and I
have never seen the room no it's crazy
what use alright so wait you you've
never seen it move never works
movie totally works movie totally still
works they kind of give you everything
you need yeah and it's a lovely story
well if you like making movies it's a
movie about mega movies right making
movies badly thank you well story of my
life
what else you watched I watched Coco did
you oh [ __ ] mark put it on his mark put
it on his top ten list and you know that
made me go [ __ ] I'm gonna watch this now
and what an emotional [ __ ] experience
that is it made me sad that I didn't
grow up Mexican oh my god how beautiful
like everything about this is beautiful
and [ __ ] a wonderful story I couldn't
like honestly bawling throughout like
and and really richly invested an
incredibly [ __ ] imaginative like just
great a Pixar loved it absolutely
[ __ ] loved it forced my wife to watch
it my wife's like I don't really want to
watch this cartoon and I was like come
on man I think this is all I want for
Christmas watch Coco that array asked
for Christmas [ __ ] this was all a
lie you know I was like this is all I
want and so she finally watched it with
me and she too was all like like I lay
on the bed watch a movie she sits on a
couch that's like a few feet away and
like you know periodically like
something wonderful happens or something
emotional and I will look over like like
an 80 year old woman I get like the
vapors I go and look over at her and she
either laughs at me not to rise of Lea
but
Kevin you're such a [ __ ] or looks back
and it's just like he like she too is
grabbed and there were a bunch of
moments where she too is clutching her
chest breathtaking it's wonderful
storytelling III saw the one-two punch
of the darkest hour where Gary Oldman
screams the whole movie pretty much that
in Dunkirk which oh it's a good double
feature man very good double feature
because darkest hour is all about the
things that lead up to the retreat and
Dunkirk I did him in Reverse though I
watched Dunkirk and then I watched the
other thing so when they started talking
about Dunkirk I was like well I know
what that is
it all comes out okay Dunkirk was
wonderful I haven't seen it when it was
in theaters if there's it's you know
it's I love the structure of it but
breathtaking filmmaking I gotta find
different word but it's it's really
fantastic but there's no emotional like
you know yeah Nolan's not great at that
we related a lot of things he's not
great at like human emotion about things
and if you watch any of his movies
they're all very kind of antiseptic and
sterile almost and I just don't know if
that's a gear that he has or cares to
get it's like [ __ ] I make beautiful
things they don't all have to make you
cry yeah and the thing that should is
the kid on the on the boat and that's
the closest thing where you feel - like
oh my goodness but yeah but in terms of
filmmaking notes but it's once they
breath take it again it is if she
blended it was a stone and it really
took me into a story where I didn't see
it when I was out it just didn't really
peak my fancy but I was sucked in within
the first like ten minutes Wow
Tom Hardy's in it anywheres a [ __ ]
Bane mask the whole movie so I was
treated like a sequel to The Dark Knight
Rises man how's it go so this what
happens to Bane he's like I'm trouble
through time to fight the wall
in this movie I'm the hero that won't
take 8 years off like a little baby it
was good I saw that what else I see did
you see the killing of a sacred deer no
[ __ ] this movie one of the most
astonishing flicks I've seen all year it
just it's what's the word man it is
off-putting but in the best way
keeps you off balance by the guy that
made the lobster yeah you're both Lum
cymose never saw now I desperately want
to watch everything he does coz this
movie like was next-level [ __ ] it's a
revenge story but you don't know what
the [ __ ] going on for the first twenty
thirty minutes maybe more really trust
that the audience will catch up
doesn't spoon feeding you a spoon feed
you info and is it is so I don't know
Maj is the shining terms of its look the
symmetrical photography the sound design
the score it's not a blood and gore
horror thriller but it is one of the
most unsettling films I've ever seen in
my life
and there's one and I can't I don't want
to go into detail you have to I can't
tell you anything more because it would
ruin the trip but it's it's got what's
his name
bullseye Colin Farrell's in it Nicole
Kidman's in it and this guy who was in
Dunkirk who was the kid on the boat of I
don't want to say anything more in
kitchen suit movie he plays the boy in
this movies so [ __ ] good then the
movies darkest [ __ ] man it's just so
it's a mind [ __ ] it's worth your time
Zhan I to to track it down I can't
there's so many things I want to say
about it there's just one [ __ ] scene
that blew my mind which is a dialogue
scene that I'd never [ __ ] I want to talk
about I talk about her does it spoil it
yeah what is it
killing of a Saiga deer so don't spoil
it then so don't spoil it all right I
know but I wanted to tell the story
next time see it [ __ ] watch it
there's this there's a moment where
Colin Farrell has a discussion with his
son his young son in the movie that's
like one like I say this is the guy that
made the walrus movie is one of the
weirdest [ __ ] things I've ever seen
in a movie in my life well okay here's
what we'll do
everybody come back next Tuesday and
we'll talk about still artists I could
be oh my
we got another show on two we got two
tickets Aziz Montcalm what else have you
seen
I saw the post yeah I like that I cried
like a [ __ ] baby at the end of the
post did you I really did because rarely
does one get to see journalists as
heroes I having been a recovered
journalist was like oh [ __ ] we're wait
we're the heroes of this and the big
[ __ ] climax of the movie is the
reading of the Supreme Court ruling
saying that the press exists to benefit
the governed and not the governor's and
then watching the news and like holy
[ __ ] this is the most timely movie I've
ever seen and just bawling like like
that kid in a printing press and if
you're like have you never cried
standing in front of a printing press so
much news I thought you might be kid got
sucked up into the printing press every
known crappy one quick cry of like I
mean that's it and then in the pages it
just oh yeah I enjoyed that movie quite
a bit if you're a big mr. Show fan it's
the movie for you because both Bob and
David are in it it was I don't know if I
talked I think I talked about here lines
up perfectly the end lines up perfectly
with the beginning of all the
President's Men
you could almost watch it as one long
double feature about the Washington Post
what what else did you see I saw a lady
bird how is it I liked it I didn't love
it okay primarily because I've never
been a teenage girl in Sacramento which
apparently is kind of awesome but not my
personal experience I can appreciate it
right that's the joy of cinema which is
look I can step into someone else's life
for a little bit and see what that must
be like but it's not it did not do for
me what say the disaster artist did for
me right which is take me on a [ __ ]
trip in a journey and highs and lows and
all the above oh my god
ice Mark's favorite movie of the year
was loganing oh that was well you had on
your list shape of water yes I think
that's my favorite movie of the year I
went to I saw that as well I didn't go
to see it I saw it at home on a screener
and I threw my money and buy online
whenever I watched one of my screeners
Oscar screeners I buy a ticket like at
the ArcLight just so they could be just
so nobody can be like you what could
support your industry I'm like I do I
just don't want to support it by being
there
I won't stop the car for pizza they
don't leave me they don't need me for
this
so I was I watched shape of water
beautiful I mean he won a directing
Golden Globe last night guillermo del
toro such a beautiful movie if you're a
big help
Hellboy fan though it's kind of like Abe
Sapien the movies but you know even like
whether you know his body of work via
Hellboy or not you can't deny just
stunning beautiful haunting romantic
piece of cinema pure cinema including a
black and white dance number with the
guy in the [ __ ] suit and it sounds
stupid but it's one of the most electric
things you'll see in a movie all year oh
my god I was so [ __ ] wonderful yeah
yeah I love Guillermo to death like he
he loves monsters in a way that I don't
love anything including my children you
know and they're great I mean whatever
they'll grow up and take care of me at
some point but but GMOs just fidelity
towards monsters and his affinity
towards the the misshapen in the cast
aside and the marginalized but and the
fact that he tells a love story about it
that betrays his love for the monsters
as well and it's just it's there's so
much texture there I can't get it out
for that movie
alright let's dive into the folks we got
some news everybody else let's talk
about what's happening in our industry
you know you know what movie dropped
down the Netflix
um we can have those right bright
did you see the brain I did watch Bray
d-iii before I watched it I'll be honest
like I probably I was prompted to watch
it by all the online vitriol button
people been like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] this
bright my dick and like just people
going off on it whatnot and I was like
well now I gotta watch it and I like
David stuff I you know I was the public
about like in Suicide Squad so you know
I I didn't think it would be a terrible
slog he certainly knows how to make a
movie looked a bit like training day
meets alien nation mm-hm so I got up one
morning and and I was I didn't have
anything creative to do on my own front
so I was like [ __ ] it
I'll watch it and I had a great time I'm
magic yeah I did like I'll be honest
with you I've loved how they fetishized
the magic wand like I just thought it
was cool he's like it's like everyone
was so [ __ ] pissed scared of it
they're like this is like a nuclear bomb
that grants wishes I thought that was a
cool [ __ ] line I thought I'm not a
big token guy I'm not here's my big
question though I hear I like the movie
I thought it's totally watchable what
orcs didn't toki and create orcs who i
orcs existed pre Tolkien I mean who
invented the orcs then I feel like
there's some like fairy tale version of
that thing like work slash trolls slash
it's like another world slash yeah I
think the yeah I feel like it's been
around before token that was the one
thing I kept watching it going like
isn't that a token thing it sounds yes
right apparently it's not but in any
event I I enjoy did you watch it yet I
did watch it and what do you think uh I
think it's kind of nightmarish the bad
that's just me Oh nightmarishly bad yeah
no not a fan not a fan of the of the
bright because I live for world building
I live for the hey here's the thing
let's tweak something just so it's a
little bit different and then figure out
how that manifests in the rest of the
world so in this world it's oh yeah so
now there's orcs here right and they're
the the lowest on the totem pole
socially they had
betrayed that do they feel T to the Dark
Lord 2,000 years ago and I've been hated
ever since and so now we got our first
basically it's it's a it's a shoddy
attempt at dealing race into fantasy
when making the orcs the black people
but then you also have black people I
didn't even [ __ ] see that
now I honestly didn't like I'm such a
bad most things like yeah I guess joel
edgerton is that is the Jackie Robinson
of police or is like he's the first guy
on the force he's gonna be our token orc
on the fourth fairy lives don't matter
it's all becoming clear now man oh all I
kept saying was like oh it's training
day where the works but I guess it is
kind of about race at the end of the day
yeah and that the elves are rich and
probably Jewish I think is kind of what
the movie made it out to be but a little
bit unclear I got to start watching
movies with Jack I didn't see that at
all I guess wow that does work but it's
like if you get if you're gonna make the
orcs the lowest on the totem pole
socially mmm then clearly the orcs would
have been the slave class right and so
then if the orcs or the slave class then
you don't get Compton looking the way
Compton looks now you don't get black
gangs the way that you have them because
that stuff is born out of Jim Crow it's
born out of societal and financial
disenfranchisement and that's why you
get pockets of ghettos if there's orc
ghettos there also shouldn't be these
other get I was like why are there
Mexican street gangs when this is the
world you live in
why is it still like Los Angeles why
isn't it some [ __ ] to work name like
what it's it's the kind of like we're
painting it with magic dust but never
actually getting under the structure of
it so they could have instead of doing
Los Angeles said on the other side of
the country called that new work
I'm available for bright to you but
here's the thing they're making a bright
- yes they've announced they are making
a bright - right that's the news yeah
that sounded like a I'm so pleased yeah
they're doing it again well they have
invested a lot of money in this
they spent a [ __ ] ton of ninety million
to make it yeah and they said that it's
it like it did 11 they had 11 million
views in the first three days it is the
most watched movie that has ever been on
that service I don't know how it ranks
next to stranger things even if you do
the math though 11 million in the first
three days times that by 10 bucks a
ticket to go see it in the movie theater
you're opening 100 million bucks they've
cracked the code of that as well and
without spending mind you marketing
dollars that's the thing studio makes
that movie they spend 90 million to make
it probably more than they spend another
50 75 just to sell it
Netflix they don't do that they maybe
take a billboard out or two but they
don't they don't spend on they did a bit
on this one because I remember seeing
doing like football playoff games said
commercials on TV network commercials
for this in the middle of like huge
[ __ ] buys so I'm making the mouth
they I mean okay if you must but yeah
they're making a sequel the entire team
is back save max landis who wrote the
original screenplay and put together the
package himself and the original
screenplay sold for like 4 million bucks
yeah what do they call those spec spec
deal thing whatever but he's been kicked
to the curb David Ayer will write and
direct the second one himself and he
tends these add-on Suicide Squad did me
he did I think Will Smith's coming back
and Joel is coming yeah I mean the whole
parties the whole gangs back
I mean honestly like my wife is like cuz
she said something about it what did you
do this morning I said oh I got high and
watched bright and she goes you used to
be ambitious I was like
and so she's not a TV show it's a movie
two hours I was in a now so she's a
virgin thing and I said like if for
something that I watched for free on
Netflix I enjoyed myself and she goes
you don't it's not free you pay for it
so I did the math of how much I watched
Netflix for what we pay and how many
people across the household pay for it
so I probably paid about 80 cents to
watch bright was so [ __ ] worth 80
cents I her
alright so bright to is happening
whether bright to hire or not indeed and
clearly lots of people want so good for
you and also they don't forget Netflix
is like Universal so it's not just like
people here a lot of their streams they
said they had overseas and did very well
over there yeah speaking of Netflix
there's a god there's the future right
there you net foot mean think about if
they crack the code of major releases
like that as one more place to go to for
her huge blockbuster budgeted movies and
they also they got Sabrina now
yeah which they just cast yeah Kuhn in
Shipka from Mad Men Sally Draper yeah
yeah think about it like they knew from
their algorithm that Riverdale kills for
them yeah so they're like why let's see
W do Sabrina we could pay more money and
we don't have to wait for the [ __ ]
show ban so now they're figuring out how
to do TV better than TV looks like they
figured out a dude blockbuster movies
maybe not better but as good as some
major studios and stuff it's you might
you know it's a moment in time where we
might look back few years from now oddly
enough and be like wow bright was the
moment it was a game-changer
speaking of Netflix there's a rumor
going around Wall Street that a that
Apple might buy Netflix because here's
the thing Apple makes most of their
money internationally like we do they do
pretty well domestically but they have
factories that have sales organization
Tyre machineries of industry that take
place overseas and due to current tax
law all of that money needs to stay
overseas you can't just bring two
hundred fifty billion dollars back into
the US economy for reasons that escaped
me but you just can't do that
yeah who's gonna be like why not yeah
president Trump has decided why not
let's let them do that let's drop the
tax restrictions and allow them to
repatriate a one-time giant [ __ ] bale
of money so Apple will have about two
hundred and seventy billion dollars that
they didn't have before and it's just
it's like I had to sit there and be like
270 billion and so if Fox will sell for
what was the Fox deal sixty billion
dollars Disney box then Apple has 270
billion that they almost didn't even
count on having like spare change could
you imagine being like look what I
[ __ ] found all the money in the world
so there there's talk that in order for
them to immediately come into owning and
running their own internet studio they
would just buy Netflix good or bad I
mean this there is no math for whether
this is good or bad cuz this exists on a
level that nobody's ever thought about
before it's probably bad because things
you've never thought about before are
almost always bad I mean that's that's
what I would scare everybody like that
that's what is not up that's a real
weird blanket statement man that's half
of what science is just like figuring
out [ __ ] and ways that'll kill you we
invented this how will they go bad oh
[ __ ] yeah velcro sounded like a good
idea I'm just saying are you knowing
that we don't I can't say security
clearances and [ __ ]
velcro stay away from it don't touch it
don't touch it
change half there's old unicorn wallets
right now so yeah it is who knows if
it'll happen it might never happen but
the idea of a giant megalithic company
which brings you phones and then [ __ ] to
watch on your phones all at once is
is kind of insane we're moving ever
closer to what they described in network
1 Omni Entertainment System yep
what else we got DC films which is you
know had a somewhat spotty run in
theaters has a new boss I saw this but I
didn't read the article there was a
shake-up as they say at Warner Brothers
there was a shake of it was this a
Justice League related shake-up
most definitely people getting punished
people getting punished people getting
reassigned this is that moment in
Goodfellas where they start finding all
the bodies and you're like well they're
playing bucking eric clapton yeah this
is a Layla moment a guy named Walter
Hamada who was one of the executives at
Warner Brothers who oversaw it this year
and insidious franchise has been kind of
their horror genre guy for a while okay
is now taking over DC films and I think
his new job is to decide precisely how
to move forward from here they only have
one film definitely on the schedule
which is Aquaman in December that's what
they have this year that's all they have
this year Marvel has black panther they
Avengers and ant-man in the wasp that's
coming out and 28 August yeah so when's
Avengers come out May May 5th oh my god
like three months after the Avengers
they're like here's another look at our
[ __ ] dick again every three months
you get the giant dick of all his
[ __ ] crazy man and meanwhile DC's
like the fish stories coming we're all
gonna talk in underwater bubbles I look
forward to that but it really it feels
like back the plan was to have a Batman
movie right about now
the plan was for Batman movie the plan
was also a flash movie I think we're
supposed to have happened by now and I
think that this guy Walter Yamato was
also helping oversee Shazam oh so you've
been working with Geoff Johns and making
that come off and that's supposed to
start shooting by the end of this year
with the guy who did Annabel creation
right so yeah DC is in a bit of flux but
at least they're promoting dudes to
hopefully right a [ __ ] who went do you
know who got fired John Berg who was the
co-head of DC films
was given a production deal which is how
you get fired in Hollywood which is they
just let you produce movies but don't
decide which movies to produce his Jeff
still in the mix Jeff he's still in the
mix as far as I can tell sue curl she
just got a production deal at Warner
Brothers she's no longer the head of
marketing she's now just going to be
produced around a lot
yeah heads rolled heads heads rolled as
we knew they what with a new with
someone new in charge maybe will
there'll be a vision that will hear
about soon and and they look they know
they've got something they may have just
Aquaman this year but they have gold and
Wonder Woman and they know they're gonna
do Wonder Woman - patty Jenkins is doing
it and stuff so that's that's something
to build on smells like they might go
back to like hey man we just make
standalone movies we don't feel the need
to connect them I mean that to a certain
degree that always kind of should have
been their model mmm you know like
Marvel came out of a gun so [ __ ] fast
and they built their universe and they
did they put in the work and Warner
Brothers went to shotgun a universe into
existence without doing the work and
maybe that's just not their play maybe
they need to Zig water metal sags as
opposed to keep zigging name is my new
reggae rap album Chesley should be
coming out any minute right should be
thanks very soon yeah soft cover for the
blu-ray and it's the wheat and weed
inversion with extra Whedon footage I
believe not close to the Zack Snyder
version I saw when I was in Florida
somebody tweeted a picture of a bunch of
cosplayers in front of Warner Brothers
holding up a sign that said release the
Snyder version that was the hashtag yeah
I saw James Gunn had retweeted a thing
where somebody was like hey man would
you donate to this this petition and and
chip in some fun so we can convince
Warner Brothers to release the the the
Snyder version it was like what a
brother's is not my favorite charity
that I will instead for every retweet of
this donate a dollar to the World
Wildlife Fund or something like that
like if what about this wants to put it
out they don't need our money they don't
need petitions they will just do it and
they will do it at some point because
they like making money just not first be
amazing you and I call to mod like this
is Warner Brothers mark we need you help
we were going to do this first all right
where do you go next our favorite French
director didn't even knew then he didn't
use again this I know you're so excited
or astonished this one's a good was a
good one okay is he French who is he
Canadian I think he's french-canadian
yeah good say thanks splitting the
needle on that ass he turned down James
Bond Oh they'd offered him bond 25 and
he turned it down to make dune right on
well yeah I mean I interviewed him on
the boat for IMDB last summer at
comic-con and he deeply in in love with
doom he loves Lynch's version but he's
like there's a version of that that
hasn't been made yet and I love that
book and Bubba book so good he gets to
make his passion project rather than
like hey he's talented let's put him on
bond or something like that you know and
he said yeah well I would love to do it
I think you know Daniel Craig's amazing
and I love bond I always have but I'm
invested in dune at this point and given
what he did I mean I was not the biggest
fan of Blade Runner 2049 I still watched
it I have to do that very soon somebody
almost got me to watch it recently
because I was like don't I spoil in it
do they what did they hide the weed in
the case no open she's wearing this
amazing
they know they I said without spoiling
it tell me if Rachel's in the movie and
the person's like that would spoil it
and I said alright now I'll watch it
so I got a still watch it yeah I mean
it's beautiful it's astonishing to look
at look he said he's a stylist a rare
stylist the best like it looks better
than Ridley's blade when it looks and
that says that's as deikun's shot it
right yeah this is probably I mean
there's well I don't know I don't know
what the competition there's this year
but you know Deakins is the guy that's
but he's the master every DP looks up to
him and he still hasn't won one of these
dopey trophies and stuff was one year he
was nominated against himself and he
couldn't [ __ ] win so hopefully this
is the year maybe you know even if Blade
Runner
20:49 ever the most important didn't do
as well as people hope hopefully they'll
recognize the artistry to give that
excuse me give that man a trophy for the
first times the Sam Jackson of
cinematographers or the Susan Lucci if
you will I mean how do you want a lot
longer true but he's a lot cooler very
true
all right what's so good for him he's
got artistic passion like Jesus I would
kill I saw doom again over the break
because it was on [ __ ] Cinemax or
Davis yes we've tell all I see isn't the
tradies I want to kill what else we got
Ridley Scott wants to make a young
Merlin movie I mean how do we I'm I'm a
little bit done with the you know that
here you really love here's how he was
before he did any of this [ __ ] that's
awesome as long as they don't guy Richie
King Arthur it man that's that's fine
that was a little too modern but yeah it
wasn't there a Merlin TV show I guess
sure Ridley Scott I mean come on give
him the better the doubt I'll watch
anything that he does I watched all the
money in the world yeah how is it really
enjoyable like I mean in a weird way
because it's about a kidnapping where
kid gets his ear cut off spoilers but
but hey man it's history but uh man his
dad built a museum yeah apparently
everybody knew this story except me but
it was what's what's insane about the
movies when you watch it you know
used to have Kevin Spacey in it and they
announced hey we're gonna replace Kevin
Spacey with Chris Plummer I thought they
would do it like digitally I thought
maybe he was in like a couple scenes he
is
it's like Michelle Williams and then
Chris Plummer that character is in most
of the movie so they reshot a [ __ ] ton
of that picture in a big bad way then I
just read an article right before I came
here that like in order to the reshoots
everybody came back like I mean he
Ridley Scott was like and they all came
back for nothing
meaning like they came back everyone
involved think about it Marky Mark he's
always working and [ __ ] Michelle
Williams she's always [ __ ] working
like it wasn't just as easy as like oh
we need Kevin Smith and Jason Mewes
they're not busy
let's get him you know like these people
went on to other things so to get them
to all come back and reshoot is a [ __ ]
Herculean effort and it just outed today
that Marky Mark's people WME were able
to negotiate money for him to come back
for the reshoot they reshot for nine
days so I guess they pay damage through
the article 1.4 million to come back for
those days which is fine he shows that
Marky Mark has some smart agents so like
Amen they need you let's squeeze him and
I got another million four of them
Michelle Williams agents didn't get that
deal for so she went back for nine days
and was paid a thousand dollars so the
day after the Golden Globes and time's
up and all that it just how did that he
she got 1% of whatever his salary was
for that nine days of work the ps2 the
story is Michelle Williams also
represented by William Morris Endeavor
yeah so the story's not great right
there and she is the movie like you know
I know he's Marky Mark and he's got a
funky bunch behind him but the but she
is the movie her performance is like is
crazy is that when you think about like
this is the girl from Dawson's Creek she
like she's an incredibly insane
legitimate actress I know she'd been
oscar-nominated she won did she
yeah didn't she did she not win for
what's my call it the Marilyn Monroe
by the city she didn't went for that I
thought maybe she would one maybe from
Maryland but no I don't think she's won
yet no but she's [ __ ] so good in this
movie and you forget that she's show she
disappears into a different role sounds
like somebody else so the movies
definitely worth watching I was watching
as a filmmaker going like this seemed
like a lot of [ __ ] work but
apparently since they had made the movie
and they were just about to lock it when
the Kevin Spacey thing happened like
Ridley Scott said it wasn't that
difficult they were able to reshoot that
much material in nine days because they
had shot it already once so he's like I
we had the blueprint we knew exactly
where to put the cameras we knew exactly
what we were going for and it was very
fast in mass media but it's worth seeing
that flick then it's a hell of a wage
gap yeah yeah right now if I'm like who
was the studio that did that yes I would
be sending her a check like for double
that amount just to be like oops
we [ __ ] up just because the story the
next day you know wouldn't be like oh my
god that wage get upset and then she
fires her agents because she totally
should fire her agents yeah I mean you
know like I hate to be that guy but like
they're all under one roof shouldn't
they be looking out for each other
we'll stay away from that who's your
agency I'm currently unrepresented by
agents
Morris Endeavor in any event let's go to
our next story our next door is our last
story there was a cartoon on the air the
Animaniacs do you remember yes that goes
Tina and Wakko wets the rain in Spain E
goes there's a joke in that show that
it's the dirtiest thing I've ever seen
in a cartoon where they're they're there
they're looking for evidence of a crime
and and Yakko says like you should dust
for prints and then dot says I found
prints right here and she's leaving
holding prints the artist currently
known as Prince and he goes no
fingerprints
and she goes [ __ ] amazing in a kids
show twenty years ago yeah but that show
is coming back Hulu just gave a no but
to season order for a revamped version
produced by Amblin with Spielberg Sam
register and Warner Brothers animation
and all of the current and all the
previous anime dates episodes including
all the spin-offs pinkie in the brain
pinky Elmyra in the brain all that [ __ ]
we're not gonna be on Hulu yeah this is
here I am all for the era of streaming
because in an effort to get nine more
bucks out of us per month or whatever
everyone's got to come up with the
[ __ ] gimmick that makes you go like
that's [ __ ] worth it and there is no
[ __ ] price that you'll not pay to
drink from the Fountain of Youth so a
lot of this stuff is nostalgic driven
sentimentality driven where I love this
[ __ ] like we're doing it again
remember what loving Will and Grace not
really here it is again remember the
office went off the air a couple years
ago it's coming [ __ ] back
so the idea like I'm I'm in line for the
Roseanne reboot you know like I can't
wait I'm like this is [ __ ] brilliant
so I'm all for it that the idea that
each one of these companies is like oh
the way to their wallets is right
through their heart so if they love this
thing let's give them more of it the
years later it'll make them feel young
again I make them seek this out because
they were big fans and so forth and so
on so I'm all for it
the flip side of that though is it
really is just gonna become the snake
eating the tail as like slowly
everything we start watching start stops
being new and starts being like remember
this we're doing it again and it's
extension of [ __ ] we've been watching
already which is fine but sooner or
later we're gonna run out of new [ __ ]
hopefully they keep making the new [ __ ]
as well but that being said I'll be
there paying for it because I'm like oh
my god that's a brilliant idea
I love that cartoon take my [ __ ]
money so I'm part of the problem as well
but it's also with with kids stuff
there's there is a slight bit of the
battery for kid I mean I mean it is it
might be for kids but you know they're
not predicating and I'm like children
will love this they're like we're going
after the [ __ ] like I got a lot
of bills and [ __ ] like that and I hate
my life and [ __ ] I just need an
escape they're bringing out a maniacs
back all right one more year to stay
alive Luther eats I need 40
cheeseburgers feel like this surge
pricing right now it's gonna cost you a
lot of money mm-hmm
that's I'm all for it man that's
phenomenal yes
bring it I mean what other carts I mean
[ __ ] if they're doing that please bring
back Tiny Toons as well that was my jam
I loved Tiny Toon so damn much I used to
record those it used to run Tiny Toons
and then right after it was a Batman the
Animated Series so I would take them
while I worked a quick stop in rst I run
over to rst set a VCR to record that
whole hour and then bring it next door
and then just catalog them before I
start buying tapes see that's the show I
want them to bring back
Batman the Animated Series like why not
yeah old school all those [ __ ] just a
lot they keep doing permutations of you
know they reinvent their their DC
properties in the animated world seems
like every two years they don't like to
let them get stale or something I think
you're right it's like you've still got
all the creative talent and they're all
willing to do it laughs why not come
back for like Conroy still alive how
much still alive Dini still alive Sam
register still alive all those dudes
just there's Tim of course what kill to
do it again I would much rather watch
another Batman animated series 30
episodes then scooby-doo and the Batman
The Brave and the bold which I'm sure is
lovely if you're eight but I I want I
want the real back you I can't believe
on one hand you're like I bring back
Batman the Animated Series while
[ __ ] in the mouths of scooby-doo and
meeting Batman which is a big part of
our cartoon heritage long before there
was a Justice League long before cartoon
Superfriends rather long before there
was like Batman the Animated Series and
so forth and so on like all we had to
look forward to with those scooby-doo
guest spots with Batman and Robin well
you were like please not Phyllis Diller
this week please please let it be that
one Batman and Robin episode you know so
I get it I think that's kind of cool and
is it when they say brave and bold is it
the Batman brave and bold version of
Batman the one that's got diedrich bader
choice then I'm on board I loved his
[ __ ] take on bat moment the fist was
that the Hammers of justice is what he
called this fist so I'm gonna buy that
[ __ ] but yeah you're right Batman
animated series I'd be down four hundred
percent all day every day and they don't
even have to wait for some streaming
service like that's weird
Hulu like Animaniacs is Warner Brothers
property so Hulu went to Warner Brothers
and said we want to do this yeah where
do you think Warner Brothers is like we
want that a someone to who we got it
who'll pay for it and who was like
here's a check so weird that Warner
Brothers like who'll pay for it I'd be
like you [ __ ] pay for me ask both of
the Warner Brothers for some money
alright we're done with the news we're
done with the news that means we move
into the section of the show ladies and
gentlemen that involves you people so
we've got to do we have [ __ ] to give
away oh my god as per usual man Deacon
Brett Deacon our buddy from 40x showed
up and he gave us some tickets to give
out if you've not seen a movie in 4dx
what the [ __ ] is your problem you might
not be lucky enough to be in a city with
a 40x theater but it's got this chair
that moves can you spread those out to
peace move phantom like a casino yeah
yeah and do a wash it's got a chair that
moves it if it's snowing in the movie
it's it's snowing in the movie theater
if you saw the last Jedi when the crawl
was happening the chair went back as the
crawl went up it's a wonderful way to
see a movie we've got it here in Los
Angeles they've got it in Chicago they
got in New York it's spreading out but
the good folks of 40x give us tickets
that wouldn't give out to people that
ask excellent questions we get
be the judge of those questions as well
questions have to be of a certain
standard you can't be like hey man when
is moose jaw's happening get off my dick
it's happening as soon as I get some
money believe it or not tough to
convince people to put in money for a
movie that's jaws with a moose instead
of a shark so some things take a little
longer bill questions should be aimed at
both of us and stuff derive some good
conversation and a good answer but you
do that and you get a set of these
tickets go see a 40 X movie so you got
the microphone JC the proprietor of this
here Cantina give it up for JC later
JC will you put your hands in the air in
JC will come over and bring a mic to you
and we'll get going with this go ahead
take us to the tickets there JC
areas are you doing guys how are you all
right two quick questions
no bad question yeah I don't get tickets
and that that's what you can't ask two
questions you got it you led with the
[ __ ] request I just set up the
[ __ ] was bad good [ __ ] question
all right ask your real question listen
to Batman of fat man I don't think
you've ever explained how you and Marc
got together to do with this new
variation of fat man in Batman so what's
the process of you guys gave together
and kind of hashing it out yeah I feel
like we've told that story but we'll get
to tell it again that's decent enough
question give it up for that question
ladies and gentlemen
I met mark through work obviously yeah
through Entertainment Weekly mark was
working at ewr cooked in a number of
places II W LA Times was the job he just
left fairly recently a Hollywood
Reporter playboy always writing about
entertainment and stuff and then
recently mark made the shift to like I'm
gonna make entertainment instead of
writing about it so he's moved away from
journalism but it's a big part of who he
is
that's how I met mark so we've done I
wound up talking to mark for a number of
things but but I've told the story
before it mark won my heart and loyalty
when as the guy working at Entertainment
Weekly he got to program a panel at San
Diego comic-con unless they're like 2007
or something like that and it was what
was it called
icon visionaries and it was Zack Snyder
who undoubtedly is a visionary and was
starting yeah they were they were in
Watchmen right Watchmen was just about
you had footage to show right so yeah
Jack Snyder like post 300 right before
he entered the hero game you had Frank
Miller you had Judd Apatow at the height
of his Apatow espouse and then one of
these things was not like the other and
I was up there as well and so you know
Marc included me in that very very cool
panel with those very cool people and
and he didn't have to it was certainly
no I was certainly by that point 2007 I
had no vision whatsoever
you know just Airy so he had me up and
that was really really [ __ ] sweet
we've known each other now for years one
day he came over to the old incarnation
of fat man Batman first incarnation was
me sitting around interviewing people
about their lives and how it lets the
character of Batman did that a bunch
then what was the first one you did it
was a Dark Knight Returns part one the
cartoon we did a commentary track for
the court - yeah so mark came on we had
a good time and
and we started doing i guess well the
youtube version happened when it was
more part than youtube yeah we started
with commentary track so we did Dark
Knight Returns part two and then we did
the timber and Batman's right and then
it was like these were fun let's keep
doing commentary tracks let's do Gotham
I'm like ah our that's right that's how
it started and we got like five episodes
in the Gotham like what if we didn't do
Gotham and just talked about nerd [ __ ]
for a while yes and oh my god season one
of Gotham broke us yeah to the point
where like let's talk about anything
else what if it was just all utility
bill let's do that it started becoming
like there's a section of the show
called utility belt where we talked
about things that weren't necessarily
Batman and the show became like a
bulging utility belt so then we started
doing the YouTube version and you just
put up cameras in your office yeah
like hey do you mind if we these guys
that define media want to like expand
and want some money on it you want to do
it over there sit sure hey man do you go
on the road let's try this live yeah man
all right sure hey this JC's got a bar
you want to do it we just [ __ ] set up
shop with the bar that'd be great you
want to do that yeah man sure it's you
saying do you want her and me going yeah
man sure that's our secret origin yeah
it's it's it's I've talked about many
times I love what the show has
organically grown into and you know just
recently I did an episode at home with
Armand Kevorkian the audio version of
the show is generally this show just
turned into audio but I did a sit down
with him like a couple months back that
we finally got to post he's the guy that
does King shark on flash makes Supergirl
fly in CW the special effects director
coordinator so you know it's they're
still interview shows and I do like
those but this is my favorite
incarnation of fat man I'm Batman and I
see largely online that it seems to
click with people as well and my Twitter
feed or you know on the YouTube feed
back it's people gone this is the
version of the show I like like once you
had an audience to talk
- like it made sense and I saw somebody
tweeted something this week where they
were like yeah I like the show but I you
know I'd like the one-on-one interviews
because now it's become kind of like
Hollywood babble-on - and I was like oh
that's why I like it so much it reminds
me of like fun like and it is cool it's
it's I have a good time doing it so
we've known each other for a while
through work and then kind of
organically it grew to this and and it's
I mean I know I should there's something
in there and I'm sure somebody could
like shred me and criticize me by being
like he used to make pop-culture but now
he just talks about pop culture but long
before I made pop culture all I did was
watch and talk about pop culture so it's
nice to be a fan I don't I don't I love
doing what I do and [ __ ] like that but
just because you get to make movies or
makes the stuff doesn't mean you can't
kick back and enjoy [ __ ] - and what got
me here first and foremost was being a
fan of things to the point where I was
like whoo I want to try it too and that
kicked open the doors of a career but
I'm very comfortable talking about other
people's stuff generally it's not in a
critical way you know I couldn't like
make fun of things and whatnot that's
Mark's job is to [ __ ] up but but I I
love doing the show like I was sleeping
20 minutes before the show began and my
wife was like get up the show is about
to happen and I was so [ __ ] tired but
as soon as she said the show I was like
Batman I'm Batman and I got up and got
dressed and almost the beacons are lit
dual Italy and got here fast and off we
went so I love doing the show with Mark
and and I look forward to it and our
friendship and knowing each other shaped
this into what it's become which is that
one of the things that most look forward
to doing like every week all right you
get tickets you get tickets you get to
go to the movies well done where we
going next JC we got Thor how are you
I'm good so my question was two-parter
real quick okay do you think they should
and will
I bring back mark hamill for episode 9
as a force ghost what's the second part
should they will they should they okay
yes and yes I mean I I think it's it's
it's a little bit of a foregone
conclusion to me he literally said see
you around kid
and I know that was a reference to like
Han Solo in Star Wars but you know he he
let us know he'll be back and that goes
Jedi's they never [ __ ] die they just
fade away and become force ghosts
so he'll be back for sure should they
yes absolutely we need to get as much
mark out of Mark as we can in those Star
Wars movies so if he becomes the de
facto Ben Kenobi who just like pops up
in every [ __ ] moving on you should
really think about this and the way Luke
Skywalker would that be fantastic
I've now like the Internet you know when
I talked about the flick is he you need
to come up Thor have an eyeline totally
but we got the cameras unfortunately a
lot of people on the internet have
really liked not turned me around but
like backed up the whole why Luke
shouldn't be on crate like physically
spoilers if you haven't seen the last
Jedi yet get the [ __ ] out of this bar
but that being said like you know first
viewing I saw the movie I wasn't like
critical about I just accept it all was
like having a [ __ ] blast and [ __ ] one
of the best times I had in a movie
theater this year second time I started
pulling at the strings and and my second
viewing at the end of it you know I was
like wow I get it I get the whole he's
not really there but but why couldn't he
have been there we've talked about this
and then like ultimately everyone has
great reasons but like yeah but you know
all all he really had to do the be there
was Ryan Johnson right he was there you
know that's it he's only as powerful or
not powerful as Ryan Johnson makes him
so everyone had a rationale for why Luke
didn't go let him physically and whatnot
but the one that I really liked was I
just read a [ __ ] I wish I could remember
but it was on like Twitter moments they
went through this whole thread and the
idea was he snapped on his lightsaber
and creates kylo Ren you know in that
moment where suddenly his nephew Ben
sees what he thinks is Luke thinking
about killing him and we learned that
Luke did have a moment where he was just
like I could kill baby Hitler right now
and and he don't do it but kylo Ren
catches them and that created kylo Ren
so Luke was not going to like it would
be stupid for him to be like and now
I'll fight you to the death because it
would have made everything that kylo Ren
feared correct and so Luke in Empire
Strikes Back
he's on Dagobah or Dagobah and and gets
like the sensation my friends they're in
[ __ ] trouble and he's like I gotta go
help him and Yoda is like [ __ ] save
him you can't or whatever [ __ ] and so
you know he's like if you leave now your
training and [ __ ] he's like I got a
[ __ ] try so he goes and things get
[ __ ] up you know he doesn't save Han
and [ __ ] like that and Yoda was right he
probably shouldn't have [ __ ] him right
so in the third movie you know the
emperor is like and Return of the Jedi
he's like yo fleets is quite lost grab
your weapon strike me down he's trying
to get him to [ __ ] go and he does at
first it's like you piece of [ __ ] he
gets it he tries to fight him and you've
seen the movie Vader stops him and stuff
and then they have the big lightsaber
fight but then when he gets the upper
hand on Vader and he could [ __ ] kill
him and neighbors like do it [ __ ] you
know kill it would kill your dad and
he's like I won't do it he snaps his
lightsaber off and [ __ ] throws down
that's the same [ __ ] guy he was the
dude that was always trying to make a
journey like he believed in the force
and the Jedi and stuff like it was
important to him like this is the Jedi
way and I won't kill and [ __ ] and he's
like then you'll die and then his dad
saves him we know the rest so that's
very in keeping for that guy to be like
I'm gonna show up on crate but not
really be on crate
I'm not he never [ __ ] puts a
lightsaber on kylo Ren even as a force
projection he's just always [ __ ]
backing off and ducking and stuff like
that so it is very much in keeping with
the character but yet people like
that ain't my Luke Skywalker and then
I'm like wow it really is like I think
in the Marvel ization of our
entertainment we expect our heroes now
to be [ __ ] superheroes gods who can
do everything but in those movies they
never set those guys up to be gods like
Ben Kenobi was an old man and he could
be like you don't remember [ __ ] but
that's like that was his biggest [ __ ]
power and stuff Yoda you know could like
lift an x-wing and [ __ ] but he wasn't
like let's go take on the Empire and
[ __ ] kill him all like he was like
I'm an old man I'm [ __ ] gonna die in
the next movie so that's what they had
with Luke it was almost like the person
wrote in their Twitter feed like Ryan
Johnson really had no choice but to go
with that rendition of Luke particularly
with the version of Luke he was left
with at the end of force awakens the
force awakens crawl is like Luke
Skywalker is missing so the story is you
know presumably about we got to find
this [ __ ] guy at the end of the story
they find the guy and give him his
lightsaber here's your metal dick back
and then at the beginning of this movies
like [ __ ] this and throws in [ __ ] we
spent two hours for him to get back to
the place where he's like oh I could do
this without doing this so we got to be
true to himself and his ideals and then
people point out he couldn't have left
dok2 because or octo he couldn't raise
the [ __ ] ship out of the water the
water ate that [ __ ] you know the
connectors and [ __ ] some people were
like you ever gotten water and your
[ __ ] car and I was again I lived
through a flood [ __ ]
and so they were like well that's what
happened I was like all right fair
enough and they said that astromech
droid without an r2 unit there's no way
it could make the jump to Lightspeed so
there's all these practical reasons
which we agree that Rian Johnson easily
could have righted it away right I want
him to leave you know what he leaves
yeah but being what they did what they
did I am I'm comfortable with it I kind
of dig it I like the idea that he
tricked the first order and I like the
idea bless you that he didn't physically
like he was gonna die he didn't die
there on crate because then the first
orders like we killed that Jedi Master
and [ __ ] but instead he [ __ ] them all
he's just like I'm not you didn't see
anything and he wasn't there
and everyone is gonna hear about as we
saw from those kids at the end of the
movie telling the story of what we just
watched so like this [ __ ] showed
up and he wasn't there he tricked these
[ __ ] there's hope in the galaxy and
if he's not dead that means at any
moment he could come back and be like
whoo
so I like it I've really come around to
kind of digging it you know internet
helped in a big bad way I know usually
the Internet's like [ __ ] it to death
[ __ ] it into here but the internet
was helpful on that one all right I you
think you're like not for me not for me
I still but whatever I do think that
given that these nine movies have been
about the Skywalker family and if you
don't have Carrie Fisher to be Princess
Leia in nine you need Mark Hamill to
carry that legacy into that movie so I
think purely as a you know mercenary
logical logistical real way of looking
at it you kind of have to you kind of
have to and I think you should I think
you know we need that we need a little
bit more closure than we got so yeah I
think we definitely see him again they
they killed Han Solo in force awakens
they killed spoilers they killed they
killed Luke Skywalker in the last Jedi
sadly carries past so they have to deal
with the Princess Leia at all but what
do you think is the next big loss
they'll never kill Chewie
because Chewie you could be chewy for
400 years it's a guy in a suit yeah they
won't kill the droids that could be
anybody and stuff but I wonder if like
but they got to kill something that
makes us go now I thought I loved the
hat from our childhood next one what do
you think it will be no cuz thinking
they're not the droids because they can
just change those forever electeds I
think it's I think it's the Falcon
I think I think there's ice I didn't do
it I think it but that would really rip
all our hearts out and at the same time
you know legacy cast is gone
maybe they don't necessarily like if
it's a big enough story beat like I bet
you that's there's a beach in in
Battlestar Galactica the the refurbished
version of it we're at the very end of
those four years and you see the
Galactica that had been through all
kinds of [ __ ] like atmosphere flying
dropping pops in and out of the dumps
like it had just it was it was barely
held together by dreams and seams and
you get that one last ride of the
Battlestar Galactica and it's beautiful
it's heartbreaking and it's it's an
elegy it's it's it's requiem for a
heavyweight and I think that there's a
world that yeah like you could if you
reckon the Falcon in the perfect heroic
sacrifice then yeah that's beautiful
like if like a the Falcon like in this
movie you know the ship that like you
goes through the Snoke ship if it had
been the Falcon them suicide run yeah
people be like ah but I get it you know
somebody pointed out on Twitter I was
like that's a [ __ ] good idea like I
was saying they had Laura Dern's
character be the one that turns a ship
around takes the jump to Lightspeed and
it was a wonderful moment with that that
moment was when the greatest moments in
Star Wars movie like oh [ __ ] as they
were doing it I leaned forward in my
seat and was literally just going no no
like I was so happy of seeing something
new that I'd never seen before
but then after when I saw the movie
second time I was like oh [ __ ] man it
would have been better if general Organa
Princess Leia was the one that was like
I'll do this [ __ ] and then [ __ ] she's
the one that takes a ship because she'd
been fighting these [ __ ] are all
[ __ ] life and for her to like you
know the only way to protect the
resistance is gonna be me [ __ ] it I'll
do it they didn't make that choice
that's [ __ ] fine somebody on Twitter
though pointed it out like why didn't
they let it be Admiral Ackbar
because he got killed in that [ __ ]
scene he gets blown out the back window
like everybody else and [ __ ] but that's
it like it was a wasted chip because
that's like one of those characters from
the original trilogy he was a big part
of our childhood that isn't like Luke
Han and Leia that they would have gotten
tears for that fish guy if they would
just been like guess what it was a
[ __ ] trap all the way out of the trap
I might har there's a trap once again
man the internet was right like that's
it that would have been a much cooler
moment and stuff I'm sure Ryan Johnson's
like hey let me tell you what would have
been better about clerks if I had been
it was just something I read that
thought be cool all right where are we
going next and you win you know jackets
tickets you get them you got a great
question man give it up for him he won
his tickets everybody
JC where do we had to Nick hey my going
how are you what's your name good Andrew
so when you were scouting in Moose Jaw I
was in Regina shooting and I had heard
that you had applied for Christmas cash
one funding they I didn't apply for it
they were gonna give me I think it was a
quarter of a million yeah
like it's not a rebate program up there
it's like it's like a fun system yeah
yeah it's really different it used to be
a tax rebate but anyway I I was also and
I put some stuff in for development but
I'm interested to know if there is
anything that you've experienced as
different in terms of funding projects
in Canada versus LA or or filmmaking in
places in Canada versus LA because I've
recently come from Canada so want to
start making things here and wondering
if you've experienced different things
it's tough because that doesn't include
marking the question I have so many
thoughts about International Canadian
finances scheme
kind of the idea lessons like not the
maple syrup two dollar exchange rate is
strong enough then it's totally worth
doing
I let me see to go here that I've I've
made two movies set in Canada that
neither were shot in Canada
so even tusks was made in North Carolina
and yoga others was made in Los Angeles
so I haven't figured out how to work in
Canada yet other than like you know I've
gone up there to shoot flash and and
Supergirl and I go up to shoot another
episode of flash at the end of the month
so I don't know how the how what the
cross exchange program is I know that
whenever I go up north if I'm working on
a Canadian production I can't write or
direct because those jobs get given
generally to Canadians first so I and
that bless you and I tried to do two
Grassi years ago I tried to write in
direct an episode and called up Linda
Schuyler to be like oh my god I was big
fan of the original series I'm watching
this next generation I see you're taking
the Joey and Caitlin characters and
you're gonna put them together I would
love to be the guy that writes and
directs those episodes and Linda
Schuyler was like oh you can't she said
the you know that obviously we were
funded by the Canadian government so all
the key roles have to be filled by
Canadians she's like I'd love you to
have you write and direct those episodes
but you can't because you're not
Canadian the first time ever anybody
ever told me no for that reason you know
you can't fight that normally if
somebody's like no like you can't do
this I was like I'll show you but like
you know like you can't do this you're
not Canadian I was like I'll [ __ ] I'm
not you know shut me down quick but I
don't know I don't know how is the
question more about like how to work
down here I guess yeah I don't know I
was gonna ask you how to work up there
because that's that's my dream yeah we
should flip lives but yeah I wish I had
more information but I don't sadly all
right where we gonna go next yes
oh good evening hi is that a Darth Vader
shirt dress with this no it's a dud
Vader dress that's badass
this is [ __ ] cool man anyway back to
you my question is kind of back to Star
Wars The Force awakens
I'm not force awakens on last last Jedi
I love that movie and yet online not a
day goes by that I see an article so
imposts on Facebook but hate on it I
haven't seen this much hate since the
acting of Krishna hey Benson and Jar Jar
Binks and I don't I'd like to opinion of
why you think there's so much hate I
think and that's good we could both have
that I think at the end of the day
audience expectation plays into that
like you know when you're like alright
the next movies gonna be all about Luke
and I've seen Luke in the trailer and I
know exactly who Luke Skywalker is and
now he looks like obi-wan so he's gonna
be like this version of obi-wan and then
they give you a version of Luke that
even Mark Hamill reportedly was like I
don't know is this really supposed to be
Luke Skywalker he's not the one I
remember some people it hit him the
wrong way and a big bad way I've seen
it's not just people going like I didn't
like it when they don't like it it's
vitriolic as if you know somebody [ __ ]
up their childhood a lot of like [ __ ]
Disney Star Wars I can't stand this
anymore
I saw one tweet where they were like
it's a great Marvel movie but it ain't
no Star Wars movie and stuff and that's
even that's a tepid criticism of the
movie there so I could figure though as
the luke angle if they had just made
Lucas superhero like everybody seems to
remember him but he wasn't really they
would have appeased a lot more people
maybe not you know letting them die in
that one maybe saying that saving it for
the next one but if you don't have a mic
it doesn't work
the beauty of these films is how the
light over overcomes the darkness in the
universe and there's going to be tragedy
hmm as well as comedy traditionally so
some people have a hard time accepting
that mmm I mean I think there's also a
sense of ownership that that fans have
felt about Star Wars for a long time
that it's such a part of their childhood
was such a part of the fabric of their
their upbringing that that there's an
illusion that Star Wars in some way
belongs to us it doesn't really never
really has like our ticket price allows
us access to see the Star Wars it
doesn't ever no matter how much we've
spent on it it never belongs to us and
that's how art works art belongs to the
artists they can share the art with us
you know mass art belongs to everybody
belongs to everybody gets to be enjoyed
by everybody but it's not ours and so
the sense that Star Wars did things I
didn't expect or maybe went directions I
didn't like chafes against that idea
that Star Wars is mine Star Wars is a
part of my personality in my persona and
I've invested so much time and energy
and money in it that I feel like I have
a say in it but that's just not the way
it works that's not the exchange that uh
that we're dealing with and I think that
that for the first time bumped up
against people in a real way especially
the force awakens was so much about
nostalgia so much about just like giving
you the things that you knew you want I
want to see the [ __ ] Falcon I want to
hear TIE fighters I want to I want to
hear lightsabers click on earth I want
to hear and see all this [ __ ] and for
better or worse that's where force
awakens did it it really did the fire of
the rebellion but this was a movie that
was bound and determined to surprise and
take us unawares and in many ways
confound us by design and some people
just couldn't swing with that and which
is fine which is fair we're allowed to
not like a movie but the level of
ownership people feel directly
contradicted that sense of being able to
let go and it just be a movie also I
think it's ironic that you know some
people who complain about the lab
Jedi are like this st. the Star Wars I
grew up with man this ain't the George
Lucas Star Wars and you know when George
Lucas went back to Star Wars everyone
was like go home so you have the guy who
created Star Wars make three new Star
Wars movies everyone was like he forgot
how to do it he should [ __ ] go away
and he went away and now people like
where the [ __ ] is that guy because
they're ruining things it just proves
that the audience is fickle as [ __ ] and
I think you know once you move away from
the maestro himself you know George at
least was a producer and a storyteller
on Empire and Return of the Jedi but
these last two movies famously he has
absolutely nothing to do it marks right
with force awakens you get the nostalgia
rush so like you're maybe maybe we
weren't as judgy about that movie as
people are being about last jeddak it's
like we're gonna give it we're gonna
give you we're gonna make three Star
Wars movies here's the first one and
there ain't a hint of Jar Jar in it
enjoy you know and so the audience just
like oh god it's [ __ ] back and now
that they've had that moment the next
one had a tall order because you lose
the joy of surprise and like your
childhood is back and [ __ ] and now you
just got to tell a real story that will
further the story build the world make
people interested in stuff and people
are less forgiving under those
circumstances and and Ryan built
something that wasn't you know JJ built
a puzzle box where he's like what's
gonna happen next where the lightsaber
come from
what does Maz know what's Rey's real
parents names and [ __ ] like that and
Ryan's version was just like this don't
matter if this don't matter if this
don't matter none of these things matter
and the force is not something you've
ever really seen before here's a true
representation of what it is they did
something different and I think that's
when people come out of the woodwork and
be like who is this guy why is he able
to [ __ ] tell the story George Lucas
never did that with these characters
people get indignant on behalf of the
creative element for telling a story
that stretches what they know about it
like think about it they did more with
the force in that movie than they've
ever done in any of the flicks
much so they make jokes about it like
it's not just about moving rocks and
[ __ ] like that and then they move rocks
but uh I think it's that I think I think
anybody who made that movie I don't care
who it was they were gonna receive a far
more critical eye and going over than
the force awakens god yeah and there was
a thing I mean I talked about a little
bit on Twitter
a week or so after seeing the movie and
it was a bit of a harsh awakening a rude
awakening for me but in looking at the
way I feel about Star Wars and looking
at Star Wars movies the dirty secret at
least for me is that none of them are
really that good dramatically like as
far as literally structural dramaturg
they're not great movies they have
amazing moments they have moments of
magic and those moments of magic post
you through the rest of those movies but
Star Wars you spend 40 minutes in the
desert with droids before you meet your
protagonist that is bad structure that
is not how you invest an audience in a
movie it just isn't but you get amazing
[ __ ] moments you get Empire which I
love to death there's 40 minutes in a
swamp I fall asleep in every time I
watch because the movie just stops cold
like sometimes these things aren't great
but we love them and the moments in them
are so great that it helps us overlooked
it gives us that childish sense of
wonder and reimagining and reawakening
to it that that's the stuff we fall in
love with and so for as bad as even the
[ __ ] prequels are each of them has a
moment that is pure [ __ ] Star Wars
yes you get [ __ ] Jar Jar but you get
duel of the fates like yes you get the
[ __ ] we're fighting investigating
crime and a diner in space in the past
for reasons I can never understand with
a six-armed chicken sure why not
but you also get like the fight on
Geonosis which is beautiful and it's
just pure cinema every one of those
movies has something amazing some have
more than others and those are the ones
we love but none of them are great
movies in the way that like oh [ __ ]
aliens is a great movie Raiders is a
great movie Goodfellas is a great movie
Star Wars is a magical
you know and I think that once you
recalibrate your perspective into like
I'm not looking for it to be amazing I'm
looking for moments that make me feel
eight again then that's how you manage
to see your way through even a movie
that's like alright if I can force
awakens' sure it's a rehash but I
[ __ ] got moments I got a lightsaber
flying into the arms of a girl I've
never met before
that's an amazing moment it was the best
moment a movie I'd seen that year also
it's like way more competitive now right
like when they told those original
stories there's nothing else like it out
there and now there's a lot of things
like that it paved the way for other
things and yeah they're not all is
important and tie back to our childhood
is Star Wars but like now there's
fantasy everywhere you know we live in a
world of pop culture and like the movies
cater pretty much to the tastes of those
that like that flick and we've seen
sophisticated treatment of you know
material most people dismisses juvenile
and done you know you know way better
way than some flicks that we've seen
within the Star Wars universe it's just
harder to impress people now think about
all the choice they have like at the end
of the day if you were to watch you know
[ __ ] the The Phantom Menace after you
watched any random episode of black
mirror you'd be like you know because
the bar for like what's [ __ ]
entertaining or what's new or what
captures your imagination keeps getting
raised not just cinematically but with
like streaming and everything like that
I you know I don't I don't envy anybody
that has to try to tell a massive story
about you know a commercial movie at
this point because it's tougher to
impress the audience it ain't even
enough to do it with the brand name
anymore to be like this is a Star Wars
movie and stuff as we see we get a bunch
of people going not to me it's not go
[ __ ] yourselves so we'll see how it
effects the next movie box-office wise
is doing just great imagine it's number
12 all-time I think yeah it isn't he's
like we're worried about the next one
oh no maybe we'll change for you
yourselves yeah but I don't if I don't
split them and be like the Disney
version of Star Wars versus the classic
old version of Star Wars I think they're
I think they're doing a good job
like I've enjoyed these flicks and I I -
also don't understand the intense
vitriol for that movie it's one thing to
be like I don't like that movie but it's
another thing to be like it's no movies
a [ __ ] abortion of cinema later you
get the tickets well-done give it up for
America where we going next Casey hi I'm
here first time it's great place isn't
it yeah Cantina is a great place to hang
out we'll likely kill you in the morning
there's questions for both of you guys
what are your definitive Batman stories
within comics one particular story and
how have those stories affected your
careers or writing thus far within your
career you mean we got to talk about
Batman yeah it's a good question okay
mine hands down is the Dark Knight
Returns at a certain point in my life it
became my Bible not just like oh I like
this story I've said many times one of
the greatest pieces of American
literature ever produced just also so
happens to have a lot of Batman in it at
the same time that book has a line on
the first page that like I I used a
point in my life where I was wasn't sure
what to do with the rest of my career
and stuff like that so very as the
moment in the beginning where the first
page of Dark Knight Returns and Bruce
Wayne is racing a car and he's an old
man now and [ __ ] like that and the cars
gonna lose control he's racing at Ferris
air try every track race track or
something like that and he talks about
like the he takes the Machine off of the
computer he's driving himself and it's
gonna he's going into a controlled
[ __ ] slides gonna hit a wall [ __ ] and
he says this would be a good death and
then next panel he [ __ ] saves himself
but not good enough and turns and the
adventure begins that story could end on
page 1 with a guy who's like I used to
give my life for this [ __ ] City
now I've just been out of the game for a
while and I never died at the hands of
the [ __ ] Joker or the [ __ ] penguin
and if I got a dye rug driving around a
race car [ __ ] it like this would be a
good death and in the last second like
decides but not good enough and [ __ ]
starts the story and I remember when I
was this is so it's not an exact
parallel but when I was working at
Warner Brothers on cop-out after we were
done with the movie war mode was very
happy with the flick and gave me a stack
of scripts five scripts that are like
ticket pick the next one do another one
we love working with you but I fancy
myself like a writer director and I had
some stories that I wanted to tell
rather than want to tell somebody else's
stories but I looked at the scripts and
when you become a director for hire it's
sweet man like when I do the shows when
I do like flashes Supergirl you have
very little responsibility they build
that show over weeks you just have to
show up and make people positive while
you're there that's it it's easy crazy
stupid money so the idea of doing that
the studio level where they would pay me
to like just direct other people's
scripts execute maybe try to elevate and
stuff but at the end of the day like we
just need somebody who knows how to say
action and cut and control the set and
stuff like that is a tender trap it was
a gilded cage so I sat there going like
[ __ ] man maybe I could become this guy
like the guy that just directs the
studio they like me they get along with
me and [ __ ] like that and this would be
a good death like this would be the way
to ride out the [ __ ] career you
didn't see this coming and you've done
your bit for [ __ ] king and country
and you've had your fun and you [ __ ]
told your stories just [ __ ] this is
it this would be a good death and then
instead of doing it I was like but not
good enough and then I went to red state
and tusks and yoga hosers and some
people like you should have crashed the
[ __ ] car
but I don't know it's just like that
would have been a good death man like
nice to be within the studio system [ __ ]
i de proudly eventually graduated to
making a [ __ ] comic book movie or
something like that but I didn't get
into this to do that stuff like you know
I love watching that stuff but I didn't
get into it to make that stuff I got
into it to be me
just like [ __ ] Bruce Wayne didn't get
into that car to [ __ ] die just by
going around the track he's like like if
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die [ __ ]
fighting for Gotham and [ __ ] and mine's
not nearly as [ __ ] noble I'm not
saving anybody the only thing I'm saving
though is like down another the
conscious the conscience and the
integrity of the kid that started this
journey every day in my life I think
about the kid that started all this the
guy who saw slacker was like [ __ ] I want
to make a movie and [ __ ] like that and I
try to respect that person's ideals
because I'm far from that kid it's been
like 25 years since I've been that kid
and I like to think I'm the same person
but [ __ ] life has happened to me and
a lot of different choices come my way
and now there's family to think about
and [ __ ] like that so it's tough for the
older one gets to maintain all the
ideals that you set out for yourself
back when you started the journey but
even if it means not making as much
money cuz I money was never the aim of
this [ __ ] with me I just wanted to tell
stories so I've not done as financially
well in my career as I should have or
whatever but that's because that's not
what drove me if it means letting go of
[ __ ] money to do the interesting
thing I'd rather die doing the
interesting thing even if everybody's
like it [ __ ] sucks I was like I know
but this that's me way more than me
like shooting somebody else's script or
something like that and that came from
that book or at least that's the
justification I use whenever my wife's
like why aren't you more successful
as I read The Dark Knight Returns once
you know what about you I feel like
there's there's this legendary concert
called that the Tammy show have you ever
seen this it was a it was a teenage
using oh yeah and and the Rolling Stones
were the headliners and James Brown was
also on the bill and James Brown was
usually the headliner and so James Brown
was like listen I gave the Rolling
Stones if you're gonna make me go out
I'm gonna go out and I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill it I'm gonna leave everything on
the floor and James Brown goes out gives
its legendary [ __ ] performance and
then walks over to the Rolling Stones
and says follow that [ __ ]
literally sweat on the stage ants will
rip the whole [ __ ] stunt that's how I
feel now like what's your favorite
Batman story it is not a story it is an
image and I think Mark Millar had
tweeted it out early a couple of weeks
ago yes but it's this Darwin cook he had
done a run of covers for a month
Darwin cook did every cover for every DC
book and his Batman one or might have
been detective I'm not sure which it was
but it was literally Bruce Wayne in half
it's Batman costume half out of it cowl
Olas cowl is laying on like a chez
lounge it's a fancy word but I'm a
little French and their hair with a
Ottoman yeah and and he's bruised and
he's got bandages in his hands and he's
got like ice on a knee and he's just
scarred and bloody and Alfred is
sleeping sleeping sleeping and I'll
Fritz standing over him draping his cape
over him like it's a blanket and it is
the most tender Batman image I think
I've ever seen but it is all about
sacrifice it is all about love it is all
about passion and drive and it's all
about resilience and how all of those
things are tied into the same Gordian
knot that you can't actually extricate
from each other the gem Gordian knot Wow
that is two for two my friend new orc
and the gym Gordian knot Wow one more
pun I get a set of steak knives
but yeah it's it's it is this image that
encapsulates everything that I love
about Batman everything that I love
about Alfred who is one of my favorite
characters and everything that I love
about superhero dumb in general and that
it's about sacrifice like life life is
always easier if you just take the short
road but Bruce Wayne for reasons that
may or may not be advantageous to Gotham
doesn't take the short road because
there's also a world in which a [ __ ]
billionaire who just invest his money in
I don't know infrastructure education
you know police all the things that had
broken city needs
they don't really need people punching
each other in the face you know like how
much does that bat wing cost yeah he's
like four billion they're like that
could have paid for schools for eight
years very much you know I don't know
but t1 lines in it everybody gets
Internet wouldn't it be great no I want
a punch
you know like how about instead of
[ __ ] punch in the penguin everyone
gets free college at Gotham what is that
cool my bat bernie sanders better like I
do what I can but Bruce Wayne is a crazy
person we love him but he's a crazy
person and so his crazy person leads him
to go out by night dress himself up and
get himself beat up for us you know he's
he's fantasy Jackie Chan you know and if
you've ever seen the end of the Jackie
Chan movie you realize what that
[ __ ] does for my $8 so with that
image just it's this perfect crystalline
nugget of everything that I love about
Batman so it did not change my life it
is not the thing that sets me on the
path every morning but you know
sometimes you're gonna follow James
Brown
[Applause]
you get the tickets you get those
tickets you have a lady JC well done all
right we got one last set of tickets
folks one last question she's not a lady
my wife's a lady
come on submitted sausage party finally
there's a lady there's a lady right
there she's wavering one two one more
back here how about this lady
yes we just need one woman please can
you hear me hello hi I'm a woman and I
have a question about women's stuff oh
my god from Texas all the way it applies
to both me and Mark though this died
girl
given the current cultural climate and
the success that patty Jenkins had with
Wonder Woman I'm curious to know if you
guys rather which which of your favorite
female filmmakers would you love to see
attached to any like comic book
properties I would give Lexi Alexander
anything I loved her punishment movie I
thought it was fantastic
I like the Punisher series quite a bit
but her Punisher movie was like God that
is the [ __ ] character she certainly
knows how to shoot the [ __ ] out of
action she's the first person I think of
you to people Ava Duvernay who turned
down Black Panther to do wrinkle in time
which looks awesome which looks awesome
but I think that that in her hands with
her eyes I think we get a superhero
movie like we've never seen before and
Rachel Talalay yeah who did Tank Girl
and she currently does flashes she's
done a flash Wow
she's done Doctor Who yeah she did
Freddy's dead that's right
but the movie that literally ends with
that line like I remember seen in the
theater it was like oh well there's the
title
and she's just like Freddy's dead
credits you know that's marketing but uh
but I think she has got a gift for genre
and I think she's got enough miles on
her that she knows every way to not tell
a bad story and she was digging the
trench when people were dreaming about
comic book movies she made Tank Girl and
whether you you know you're a fan of the
movie or not that was a comic book movie
it's a goggle movie it's a deeply flawed
comic book movie but there are still
images and sequences in that movie that
are pretty friggin great she wanted to
do preacher for years yeah she was
trying for a long time a feature look
with a Garth and his script and Steve
Dylan mm-hmm yeah she's been she's next
what a great pole I met her up in
Vancouver she was doing an episode of
flash and she'd done a few really cool
ladyman really cool yeah like most
recently she directed the the Doctor Who
Christmas special the handoff between
the dude doctor and the lady doctor oh
she did that one yeah she did that one
where he regenerated and did that list
be kind rewind he said he did yeah and
it's it's a beautiful piece of work and
it's a great piece of cinnamon I think
that that she has earned a shot back to
reach for that brass ring yeah that'd be
my vote and to be fair like she's she's
been she's worked consistently it's not
like I give her another shot she's
constantly at work yeah I mean she got
kicked in the teeth a little bit after
Tank Girl she did it she'll tell you
about it - yeah cost a lot of money and
she was in what is commonly referred to
as director Jeff movie - Wow yeah but
she has consistently worked and worked
strong and there was no reason why she
shouldn't get a shot back at it given
there are people who've made bigger
flops than her who get to make more
movies so yeah that's my vote you
weren't talking about me were not about
I also would like to see Karyn Kusama
ticket take a shot at it I thought his
girl fight and showgirls in a on flux
she did but she did this movie called
the invitation I want to say two years
ago maybe
kind of nobody it's a super indie movie
that I think she shot in her house but
it's a it's an incredibly tense piece of
work its genre but not crazy genre and
the ending will blow your [ __ ] teeth
off so yeah I think she could absolutely
do a fantastic
I don't know America Chavez movie I
would where's the [ __ ] out of it he says
he swings a beer I'd watch my [ __ ] I
[ __ ] card Kuzma boy ladies really
well by the time we get to the point of
the show that mark is just [ __ ] drunk
it hasn't happened yet we know that it's
time to [ __ ] wrap up tickets yeah you
definitely win those tickets give it up
for a man has a great question ladies
and gentlemen of the scum and villainy
canteen have you had a good time receive
them we love doing this show man but I
don't get to have as much fun as I do
doing the show without the man standing
next to me give it up for Mark Bernard
in it we return next week what days @jc
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Wednesday the
16th Tuesday the 16th tickets available
at sea smart calm but that's all we got
for this week man that's fat man Batman
for this week I'm Kevin Smith I am
workman or tune in next week same fad
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
YouTube that calms last Kevin Smith good
night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you